Jerry I'll start with you I'm business
rates huge bugbear how much difference
is is going to make each of the
announcements that the Chancellor made
yesterday was positive so business
response has the initial response have
certainly been encouraging thank you
very much indeed this is of help but it
doesn't address the fundamental concerns
and I think that the complaints will
continue the business rate is too high
this is the highest local property tax
anywhere in the world of comparable
taxes and to lessen slightly the speed
of increase doesn't really address that
fundamental issue that the burden is too
high and of course we're going to get
three yearly revaluations instead of
five year leave potentially that's a bit
of a stealth tax some would say well I
think three yearly is positive and much
better than five ble or the last
revaluation it was extended a seven
years it is absolutely right that we
revalue more frequently so the changes
in property values in economic
circumstances flow through more quickly
into change rates bills now Wendy the
Chancellor had a bit of a swipe at
online retailers there's this royalties
tax for example on on sales rather than
profits is that going to help level the
playing field between online and bricks
and mortar retailers well I think what
we've got or what we've sort of you know
inherited over a number of years is a
tax system that was you know brought
about a very long time ago so it needs
to be modernized into the the modern
world that we all live in and part of
that we are going to see a withholding
tax on royalties paid in relation to to
sales to UK customers by overseas
companies so so it's it's one measure
but there's going to be a much wider
consultation as well I mean that
particular measure is only going to
raise 800 million pounds over four years
which put in the context of the likes of
Amazon's UK sales doesn't seem an awful
lot well that's that's as I said it's
one measure there's going to be a wider
consultation on on looking at the value
capturing the value from UK customers
who interact with online platforms so
there is a wider piece going
and there's a much wider piece that it's
an international piece and what I would
like to see is the UK continuing the
role that it's played as part of an
international push on tax and bringing
it more more globally and actually
bringing back the public's trust in
business Gerry
we also have the Chancellor saying
yesterday he was going to freeze the
threshold at which vit kicks in at
85,000 I mean that helps small companies
by and large a lot of pressure on him to
lower that particularly from the office
for Tax Simplification wasn't there well
yes this is not my area for
specialisation he has done a lot in the
context of business rates in order to
support small businesses and he
yesterday announced that he was going to
abandon the ridiculous staircase tax
that was impinging particularly on small
businesses so those aspects are are
certainly good news so on the basis of
what you heard do you think this helps
give bricks and mortar retailers more
skin in the game bit of a chance to
fight back against the online Goliath no
this is goes nowhere near far enough in
addition to the size of the tax take the
burden the retailers fundamental concern
is that they perceive there is an
unequal treatment between the business
rates and they are to pay on the high
street and the online guys who pay very
little relatively for their out of town
distribution centres or nothing at all
if they are distributing from offshore
when do you go along with that briefly
would you well in relation to v80 there
are some moves on v80 so one of the
things that is being brought in is to
make online platforms responsible for
v80 where a foreign seller has not paid
it all right Wendy Nichols Jos gonna
leave it there I'm afraid